good to see you Ryan Leaf how are you
sir PSP and college football analyst
Ryan Leaf who would have thunk it five
years ago sitting in a prison cell that
I would be an employee of the Disney
Corporation right that is one way to put
it it's just I mean it's about what you
choose to do when hit with the
opportunity to either go one way or go
the other way continue down a path or
choose to do things completely different
in your life 180 degree lifestyle change
and what kind of amazing things can
happen I mean just like there's just so
much gratitude and are in our home right
now everywhere we look last night my
wife-to-be told me she just looked at me
she's like this is we we put our son
down and and we're looking at each other
just going this is we have we have the
best life and we truly mean it when we
lay down and I don't I mean I've been
talking about it a lot lately but I just
kind of overcome with it right now it's
just it's it's pretty amazing you know
and and I could see it in your eyes
right now it is it's pretty neat it is
amazing that you but it's also hard work
you put the work in man you put the work
and you put the work in on the radio on
you're on pac-12 radio and on mad dog
radio and I'm sure you know you knocked
on a ton of doors you've you've been in
here on DP you've been with Dan you've
earned it but you guys yeah I've worked
really hard but I've had people like
yourselves and everybody else in this
business that have really given me an
opportunity to I mean when I walked out
of prison to that yeah I don't have any
AAB any opportunities the people weren't
opening doors for me you had to put in
the work and then up then people give
you opportunity and then you make the
most of you made that that point out to
me like hey you went about it in a
different way when you came on the show
you did it your own way I gave you the
opportunity but you made it your own and
that's something to be said for for the
people that stood by me and have given
me that chance well it's your honesty
too cuz you do have a lot to talk about
there's a lot that we see in sports we
see a lot of adversity in sports we see
a lot of guys who are highly drafted who
succeed we have see guys who are highly
drafted and need to find something else
to do like what you're doing right now
and then the journey
between and you put your story out on
your sleeve and you tell it like it is
and I think in this day and age where so
many people just just spew so much BS
yeah it's tough to sometimes take so
when somebody actually is refreshingly
honest about stuff that is tough to be
honest about you get flocked towards you
once you once you finally take take
solace and accept what it is I'm okay
with that you know I'm okay with
everybody knowing because I think most
of people did anyway right because it
was made really public and it probably
saved my life so just I'm okay with who
I am and that took a long time to get to
that's that's what true humility is
knowing who you are and you know just
again just ton of gratitude and the leaf
household we're really happy with what
we're about to start a sausage journey
on right now all that said what's up
what's the deal with giving you your
first gig at Tennessee I mean what the
hell is at home what's going on I will
say this people may think that having my
name associated with Peyton Manning yes
it's gonna be it's gonna be a bad thing
I think I think it's an absolutely
amazing thing everybody all right yeah
because he's one of the greatest to play
of all time right sure that means if I'm
in the conversation I have been pretty
damn good to be in that conversation
oh we're gonna I'm gonna allow that to
be a positive for me and this is a great
opportunity first game out at Tennessee
old Rocky Top never been there before in
my life yeah
hundred thousand people it's amazing um
yeah I mean there's something to be said
about it my I was supposed to go my
freshman year Peyton Manning's first
start against Washington State I was a
scout team quarterback all week playing
Peyton Manning that amazing I won scout
team Player of the Week
Washington State went down there and got
beat 10 to 9 on like the final play our
offense was we couldn't score off and
say our defense was amazing which is why
you got in there
[Laughter]
but I think it's just unique and then we
have a neat story to start with I think
they have a great jeremy Pruitt's doing
something different there he's kind of
trying to bring what he learned at
Alabama under Nick Saban to Knoxville
and I'm excited to get down there see
Knoxville I already text Peyton asked
him where to where to go eat more to go
play golf if I had a chance and then we
have that information we're all set yeah
we're also
now what does one get for being Scout
player of the week a little plaque yeah
huh
gave it to mom and dad okay mom and dad
still have it in the basement somewhere
okay now we know they're really trolling
on you if they do require you to read
the promo for Payton's ESPN Plus shell
oh no that's already happening yes
they're really trolling it I love it oh
listen peyton manning is fantastic if
everything that he does certainly if
it's personality is gonna be on display
it is a great show NFL Films is
producing it I mean come on and then
you're all you're taking off the next
week because you've got a big honor yes
you're correct I mean so ESPN gave me
the week off and week two because
Washington State my alma mater they're
gonna induct me into the Hall of Fame
what in the world is gonna go through
your temples on that day Ryan well I
think you know when I when I first
started going through this process I
talked to a lot of people who are my
mentors and stuff and we try to remove
myself from the equation as much as we
can right and this is kind of is all
about me and I at first my first
reaction was I can't do it I'm not gonna
do it and then my my mentor came to me
it's like you've gone completely on the
other end of this thing if you haven't
been the guy you've been the last four
and a half years this isn't happening so
and I'm gonna look for it as an
opportunity to talk about that team
other way that's a great way to put
about it though I know you want to talk
about the team but he's right like if
you didn't live your life the last four
and a half years the way that you have
this is a celebration as much of the
last four and a half years as it was
however long you were on the campus four
years at Wazzu I'm glad that your mentor
said that to you and we have you know we
have three players from that defense
that are no longer with us starting
defensive lineman two of which aren't
here because of the same kind of disease
I deal with that are no longer here and
so I want to celebrate them I want to
talk to my teammates and my university
about making sure to be responsible for
one another like I just talked about
mm-hmm in that Texas A&M video be
responsible for one another I didn't I
wish I'd have known what they were going
through because I was going through the
exact same thing and we can be there for
one another and this is gonna be an
opportunity to
elebrate I think it's more special for
my parents actually my mom my mom is
it's just through the moon to be able to
be a part of this that's a home that's
great
and I bring it up be able to bring my
son with me and he doesn't know what the
hell is going on - almost - who knows -
well at some point you know we'll find
the whole thing out yeah
Ryan leaf right here on the Rich Eisen
show it's remarkable funny coincidental
however you want to put it a Peter King
at the end of the conversation I just
had with him before you came out here I
asked him about the decision to start
Case Keenum overed Dwayne Haskins in
Washington and how Haskins is not yet
ready he's kind of green the line in
front of him isn't maybe up to snuff to
protect somebody with a huge upside like
that and he told a story about how Bobby
Beathard Hall of Famer that as much as
he respected Bobby Bobby told him about
a 1998 highly drafted quarterback who
might not have been ready but he's like
the fan base expects it they want him we
want him and we start Ryan Leaf were you
ready would you would you have liked a
redshirt year clearly I wasn't I mean
we've seen mentally I wasn't physically
of course but mentally I wasn't so yes I
would have loved a red shirt but guess
what the mentality my time there I was
like no I'm starting I'm starting day
one and I was always competing like
Payton starting day one I'm starting day
one right we're gonna we're gonna
compete with one another so I don't know
what you would have to do to try to hold
that back he would have had to been the
person that said hey no you're not
playing you know what Jay Gruden's doing
he know you're not playing
Dwayne Haskins we're gonna start the
veteran we're gonna allow you to learn
and get better we also cut quarterbacks
we only had two on the roster that year
me and Craig we Lahan there was a rumor
going around that they Kevin Gilbride
wanted to bring in Warren Moon to mentor
me and be the guy he'd worked with him
of course in Houston all those years and
boy Wow would that have been something
special to have Warren Moon you know be
the veteran they're the veteran
leadership part and have me learned they
brought Jim Harbaugh in the next year
and he taught me a ton voting teacher
taught me how to be competitive he
taught me how to be a professional and
by the time I finally got the
opportunity to play it's when I had you
know hurt my wrist terribly and wasn't
able to to compete at the level I was
but Jim Harbaugh taught me a lot as my
back
in San Diego those that second in third
year in terms of being hurt
obviously Andrew Luck we know what
happened over the weekend you were on
the air for your Sirius XM radio show on
the mad dog rope yeah exactly
so are there any similarities you
retired at 28 could there be some
similarities where you where you heard
this news and you heard about his
rehabbing and being in this vicious
cycle of rehab and pain and and playing
anything sound familiar - yeah I mean it
did of course I didn't have anywhere
near the success in my pro career as he
did but I was so sick and tired of
beating up being beaten up physically
and mentally as well right I was told
how bust I was he's sick and tired of
hearing when are you gonna play why is
he always hurt what's this about I can
understand that he didn't fully come out
and talk about like the mental anguish
it has but you could hear it in his
voice and in the idea that he didn't
love something as much as that he used
to so there has to be something to be
addressed there and I believe he's gonna
address it and so we may not know what a
year from now looks like but we know
right now this is what he feels is best
for him so I could I imagine that day
when I walked into Michael Moran's
office and I just told him I quit I
didn't go into that hey I can't get up
in the morning I'm feel sad all the time
I don't know what to do with this
instead I just walked in and said you
know I quit I thought his self-awareness
and his ability to express and
articulate the way he felt the last
couple nights has been so impressive for
everybody out there who's contemplating
a decision in this vein or anything that
that's the biggest thing I took away
from this is his self-awareness in that
moment to have it all kind of thrown at
him like that when he wanted to do it is
all on his own terms on Sunday you have
to come out and talk about it afterwards
to deal with the fans all the things
he's he's a perfect example for anybody
out there who who's contemplating her
thinking about doing something in this
nature moving forward now when you say
Ryan Leaf here on the rich I wasn't sure
that you could not articulate it to
coach holmgren when you said I'm out and
the way that he how impressed you were
that luck was able to do it
what anguish is there for fans who are
sitting here perhaps still not coming to
grips with Lux decision two weeks before
the season with a Super Bowl ready team
it seems what what what is that anguish
III can't know that as a fan right
because I've never really truly been one
I was a Steelers fan growing up and when
Terry Bradshaw was hurt I was you know
why isn't he sure why can't he be the
guy so I it's hard for me to do that I I
go right to the mindset of him in Andrew
Luck and and what it means to go through
what he's going through
and yeah but as a player as you do
talking about it what is that anguish
it's it's difficult right I tend not to
even look at the injury side of what
went on with me because I look at isn't
his excuse I'm still stigmatized in that
enough where I'm like you know you're
not the big tough football player right
you couldn't talk about your mental
illness with your coach you couldn't
talk to anybody after the fact like you
were banged up you were hurt um you you
took on everything else from the outside
so that the anguish builds up and it can
develop into in a dual diagnosis one in
a physical and a Defen mental aspect of
things he's probably dealing with some
sort of depression I don't want to be a
doctor or any sure of that but I mean if
you've gone from loving something so
much to now almost you know despising
being there and dealing with those
things there there's a there's something
that comes with that and needs to be
addressed and he's the person I think
that's gonna be able to go do that and
work with the transition if he chooses
not to ever play this game again my
concern is it with that and I would love
to bring this up with you in the few
minutes we have left we heard Peter King
talk about how if you know if you had a
guess one player is going to be retiring
surprisingly retiring with so much of an
upside and it would be a guy who is
Andrew Luck with his own book club and
you know and is a deep thinker that I'm
already expecting the backlash coming
from the scouting community next
February March April guy has got too
much going on outside of football
football's not the number one thing he's
too much of a thinker we need somebody
sure somebody who can understand the
game is intelligent but don't think too
much and there's gonna be maybe a red
flag
of people who sound or are as
intelligent as Andrew Luck we saw this
play out a year ago with Josh Rosen I
feel where he felt like there was too
much going on outside of the football
realm and there was kind of a red flag
attached to him that's why he wasn't
necessarily drafted as I as he was is
there is there legitimacy to that well
it's a business so of course there's a
legitimacy in them making that decision
but I guarantee you right now if a team
could say they could get Andrew Luck for
seven years as your franchise
quarterback you take it you you want one
year from a franchise quarterback if you
can get seven from somebody that's that
in my mind is good enough as a business
manager as we watch these businessmen
make these types of business decisions
in terms of what one season looks like
you can get one player for one season
like that you're okay so Scouts I know
want to be known for their their
scouting prowess on picking somebody in
their longevity right but I mean come on
the the length of a career in the NFL is
2.8 years I told everybody the other day
about I learned the Saturday working
with the NFL legends there's only been a
thousand 1000 players ever to play eight
plus years in the NFL in the hundred
years of the reasons so if your scout
out there what you got from Andrew Luck
is exceptional so be proud of that go
out and continue to do the job find the
best possible players regardless of if
they play one year or play ten years you
go out and find the best one that should
be the scouting process moving forward I
think they'll do that before I let you
go Ryan Leaf and heading off to the ESPN
booth and and continue doing everything
else you're doing you've seen Clemson up
close and personal I mean how can we sit
here and think it's not Clemson Alabama
and two teams that are gonna potentially
lose to him in the college football
semifinal obviously anything can happen
but you're already hearing that cuz no
reason why we shouldn't and having seen
both programs
mhmmm it's just there's something
different about what Dabo does down
there he doesn't bring in JC transfers
he doesn't bring grad transfers he
brings in guys they only offer 80
scholarships other programs are often
375 scholarships to me that's like what
you know there's nothing meaningful
about getting an offer from something
like that but you get an offer from
Clemson you have the right guys in there
well I will say lose
the defense they did a year ago right
now they knew what they had sure right
now there's a little you know a little
unknowns what they what they have going
on they have opening their the strongest
schedule will be the first three games
Georgia Tech on opening night Texas A&M
comes to town a week to Death Valley
then they say his alma mater and then
week three up and uh up in the Carrier
Dome I think they took carrier off it
serious SIA the dome the dome that don't
yeah
where Syracuse who I think is probably
the only other team other than then then
Clemson maybe in the ACC that could be
battle rare II you know we'll see how it
how it plays out SEC is gonna be really
weak but they have one really dominant
force and I expect them to be in the
college football playoff probably
alongside Oklahoma Ohio State mm-hmm
sorry so calm
I just I don't know if they can they can
do it this year I would love to see my
friend Jim Harbaugh and your Wolverines
get to the couldn't even I wouldn't even
know what to do with myself if that
happens well I would uh I'd be excited
for you thanks yep by the way you found
you found that excitement somewhere deep
in your reserve to be able to
communicate it to me story about that
game what is that so we're warming up on
the sidelines right this is the Rose
Bowl yeah we're one with the Rose Bowl
playing Michigan in the Rose Bowl we
rolling up and I'm coach price is
standing next to me and I throwing and I
look over there and I always look at the
other quarterbacks there's Brian Griese
and then there's just there's this kid
walking around and he's throwing the
football and he's got these shoulder
pads that come out like a like two feet
wider than his shoulders and he's yeah
toothpicks come out and Scott number ten
on and says Brady on the back that grab
I grab Mike price and I said coach see
that guy over there he's like yeah I was
like that's gonna be the greatest
quarterback to ever play in the other
smell and I hear I started off the
interview saying that you're one of your
great attributes was your honesty but he
was there that day I mean how cool is
that you know he didn't do anything that
game well he's the greatest quarterback
to ever play but it's tough throwing in
the direction of the Heisman Trophy
winner yeah he picked me off by the way
in the end zone
did he do that no you Charles and by the
way I got some of Charles's wine
his latest label interception of course
he's not a great name
it's great everybody's making a while
right bouquet good to see you Ryan leave
hey congratulations on the gig thank you
let's uh let's get you in here as much
as much as you want
yeah a schedule I'll check him out on
ESPNU 3:30 p.m. Eastern Georgia State at
Tennessee congrats in advance of that
great weekend in Wazzu coming up but for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app